we're coming to the final session of our
day one this will primarily be a
presentation by our core directors our
bbc core director dr
taylor will kick off first he will lead
on to
our um bioinformatics training uh
uh collaborator and find biotech and
then
from there on we'll lead on to our
molecular cell biology core director dr
young von lee
so uh without further ado i'd like to
hand over to chris to
get on with the bbc core presentation
all right
so um i've been associated with the lbrn
since
the beginning of last cycle as the
director of the
bbc course in the bioinformatics
biostatistics and computational biology
and over the course of that time our
approach has really evolved and as gus
mentioned earlier that you know the core
the bbc core
ultimately will be transitioning to a
data science core
so i'm a an associate professor at the
louisiana state health sciences center
in new orleans which is different from
where erska is at in northern louisiana
so we have
lsu health sciences in shreveport
and the mission of the bbc
core is really to um
you know there's a number of things that
we're looking to do
and we want to assist with connecting
appropriate collaborators throughout the
network so if somebody comes to us
and needs assistance with particular
types of bioinformatics or biostatistics
i'm a big believer that you want to
connect them with the
the most appropriate person to work with
them and that is
someone who has the primary expertise in
the research area that they need to work
in
and we also provide essential
computational and analytic expertise to
the lbr
researchers and the idea there is to
enhance their competitiveness for r15s
and other grant opportunities
and to help them to generate primary
preliminary data for for their grant
applications
we also have a major focus on educating
the lbrm researchers
in bioinformatics techniques and this
has just always been my big belief that
the biomedical researchers
need to be involved in the the analysis
of their data
because they're the ones that have the
most domain specific knowledge
and and can benefit the most from being
empowered
to to perform their own
bioinformatics analysis with our
assistance
and lastly exposing the l buren
researchers to the latest research
methods
and so i just wanted to put up you know
a map of the
of the institutions involved in the lbrn
just so you get an appreciation
um many of you already familiar with
this that the institutions are spread
throughout
the state of louisiana and we have a um
you know
a concentration around baton rouge where
the
you know flagship institution lsu baton
rouge is
i'm in new orleans at lsu health
sciences center
and then there's also contingent up here
in northern louisiana which
um that's where erska is based and uh
you know i can't say enough about
bershka she really helps to bookend as
one of our associate directors the uh
northern part of louisiana whereas i'm
primarily representing the southern part
and the way that we've got this uh the
core leadership
team structured because of
the you know distribution of
institutions throughout the state
each primarily undergraduate institution
that we work with the eight of them
have a core liaison officer and i'll go
into what those
those members do but i wanted to
highlight
um that in the core leadership team
you know erska is up there at lsu health
sciences shreveport
i'm um at lsu health sciences new
orleans and then
a number of other of our leaders are in
baton rouge
but each of them has a specific
expertise so michael berlinski's more of
a protein
structure expert i'm more of a
microbiome expert erska
she does a lot of different things rna
sequencing
and a number of different analyses and
with the new cycle we've added a
biostatistician
jew when and dr nguyen will help with
assisting our investigators with you
know statistical analysis that's needed
in in the course of their their
applications and their generation of
preliminary data
and then also this cycle we've added a
new primarily undergraduate institution
at the university of new orleans
and so we've appointed a core liaison
officer dr
hope for university of new orleans and
and i
i'm actually very happy that we were
able to add uno
because that's where i started my career
as an educator in the computer science
department
at uno and in fact i helped to to
recruit dr
hope when he was joining uno right
before i left
for lsu health sciences and so our core
liaison officers
they're really there they identify the
needs for each
for their campus and their lbrn faculty
and help to bridge the gap and
communicate the needs of their campus
with the bb bbc core leadership
they also communicate the educational
opportunities to their faculty
and they're the primary gateway for
what are called core bucks applications
which i'll get into on the next slide
that their faculty can submit and they
provide recommendations to us
for funding and then lastly they
describe to us future needs that their
campus that they've identified
and investigators on their campus that
could take advantage of of the bbc
core so the core box program
provides a pool of funding for the lbrm
member institution investigators and
they can apply
to receive core services to assist with
their data analysis this is primarily
to help generate preliminary data for
other funding opportunities
and all reasonable requests will really
um are recommended for funding and these
funds can be utilized for any services
that are available at a facility that
has
a schedule of listed fees and so some
examples is the gene lab ngs
bioinformatics corps
at the lsu main campus uh i have a
microbial genomics resource group and we
provide
services out of the health sciences
center in new orleans
um urska is involved with the lsu health
sciences shreveport bioinformatics corps
and then at the end of my presentation
um ilya brodsky will tell you about
the pine biotech partnership that we
have through the lbrn
and some of the services that they can
provide
so this is just a flyer for the uh the
core bucks program
and it you know it's distributed to the
undergraduate
uh institutions by the the core liaisons
and that
it provides them with examples of things
that can be done and what they can apply
for funding to do
and so that our researchers are
encouraged to apply for these funds
uh in terms of hardware infrastructure
we talked about you know this came up a
number of times already today but
uh there's delony hpc which is available
to all researchers in louisiana
that has its pluses and minuses on one
hand you're competing with everybody
else for cycles on these machines
but on the other hand these are open to
all researchers throughout louisiana
and then lsu's main campus has the cct
host
high performance computing which is
again available to all lbr and
researchers through
associations with the alberin
and the lsu hpc which is separate from
the ccthbc but that's also available to
all of our lbrn researchers
and then lastly i'll mention that i just
got
i'm the pi on a new nsf grant which is
through the
cyber infrastructure program and that is
a
400 000 grant that we are acquiring a
new cluster computer that we're going to
be installing at the health sciences
center in new orleans and this will be
something that that the biomedical
researchers down here have direct access
to
but also can be utilized by lbr and
researchers through
associations through the program and
this
we just got the specs on this that we're
buying it's going to have 14
140 total compute cores providing about
almost 200 teraflops of computing
throughput and then in terms of
software infrastructure there's an array
of bioinformatics software that
is maintained um on the computing
infrastructure to assist the l brynn
researchers
and um but the major you know there's a
list of
a number of different software that we
keep um
available on these resources but as you
all know the major
uh impediment to doing bioinformatics
research is not
necessarily the hardware in the software
it's engaging with the expertise people
who know how to use
these tools and to put them together to
do meaningful
uh computational biology and
bioinformatics
so that brings me to the educational
resources and the lbrn hosts a variety
of training sessions
on hpc utilization scripting and
software utilization
and there's personnel available to
assist our researchers with use of those
hpc resources
if they want to access them directly and
they can contact
our associate director nyong kim for
details on those programs but they're
also available on the elderin website
and we really like you know we want to
expose the researchers
throughout our network to bioinformatics
methods
and this is done through the elderly
annual meeting which we're holding right
now
the summer research program and also our
annual conference on bioinformatics and
computational biology
so uh this last year
in early april was supposed to be our
eighth annual
bioinformatics conference but
unfortunately due to the timing and the
quick emergence of the pandemic
we had we didn't have time to pivot our
program
to a virtual format at that time so we
actually had to cancel the meeting
and as ramesh mentioned earlier we
already had uh lined up
a presentation a whole session from the
nih strides initiative which was going
to be led by todd reilly
and we had speak keynote speakers from
the amazon web services and google cloud
research
communities and and so we've reinvited
them this year
and this is just a you know promotion to
save the date
our uh annual conference is going to be
the april 15th through 17th so that's a
thursday friday saturday and we've
confirmed that the
nih stride session is going to be held
on that thursday april 15th
and then we'll also as we circulate
we'll be circulating the flyer
in the coming month about our program
and the other imminent bioinformatics
and computational biology speakers that
we're going to
have give keynote talks at that
conference
so in in terms of educating the
researchers
about bioinformatics the the landscape
has really
changed over the course the last decade
or so and and bioinformatics is
really not no longer a niche area that
can be served
by a handful of specialized researchers
who are you know computer scientists and
mathematicians
and nearly every discipline within
biomedical research now
has the need for bioinformatics methods
so we
really you know attempt to bridge this
gap between the biological researchers
and the computing researchers
and the challenge here though is that
you need to trade this
larger cohort of biomedical researchers
and the problem with that is that those
researchers
they need not be bioinformatics
specialists but some of them will have
very diverse backgrounds and this leads
to challenges with the traditional
format
of educational programs and i found this
when i was trying to give
some of the early lecture series on on
bioinformatics where i got very
disparate
reviews from the course and some
students said it went way too fast for
them it didn't have enough
details and other students said they
were bored to tears
you know so those were the ends of the
spectrum whereas you know the primary
bell-shaped curve where people who are
very satisfied with pace the course
but with the just the diverse
backgrounds that you have coming in some
people have been programming for a long
time
other people who haven't programmed at
all it's become very difficult to
you know hold a traditional course so
the emerging solution that we have
is a bit more reliance on technology to
provide
online learning opportunities that allow
our students
to really move at their own pace which
they really can't do in a traditional
classroom environment
but online they can do they can repeat
sessions they can go at their own pace
and so
um early on i had conducted some lecture
series and
and i worked with our media site team to
capture these lectures
and these lectures persist as two
full-fledged courses one which was an
introduction to informatics and the
other which was an
introduction to analysis of the
microbiota
and all of our researchers can take
advantage of this that
all the lectures and the slide sets are
recorded along with
um you know some homeworks and
assignments
and they're available at those above
urls
and i you know after posting this i
actually got uh
you know an email from some folks in the
northern new england clinical and
translational research network and they
they had found this material and they
asked me if it was okay for them to post
it
so that their investigators could
benefit from access to those resources
so this was a
sort of a broader impact that i hadn't
even anticipated until this email came
in
and i was being asked for permission for
other people to be able to use these
these recorded lecture series which
primarily i provided for the lbrm
and so in terms of our pui usage when we
did these lecture series we we
co-enrolled uh from some students from
lsu shreveport
which uh erska helped to to direct that
course
and also southern university in baton
rouge where wesley gray
helped to enroll students from there and
they were able to
to remotely view the lectures in the in
the material in
lectures was then supplemented with
on-site experiences
from the home instructors but this
process was really hard to scale up
due to the you know just the need for
us to be split across research and
teaching and all the things that we have
to do
and so more recently we've partnered the
alburn has established a partnership
with pine biotech and they've developed
a library of courses
that much like the lecture series the
students can take at their own pace
and this is going to address parts of
the critical need for education in this
field
and initially we we established this in
summer of 2018
and we got 25 educational licenses that
we purchased through the lbrn for use
by the lbr and pui campuses and then
additional licenses
were supported through the cct and all
of our attendees worked through hands-on
educational material that was provided
at pine biotech through their edu t bio
info course portal and this was
genomics metagenomics and and several
transcriptomics courses
and all of our students were then
encouraged to present project posters
at the elder and annual meeting which
many of them did
and because of the pilot's success it's
been since expanded into a partnership
and and i'm going to hand things over
right now to
elio brodsky because he really is
going to be better to give you an
overview of the edu both the educational
offerings that pine biotech has through
this partnership
in addition to some of the
bioinformatics pipelines that they can
support
thank you
so i wanted to um thank you chris for
the introduction
and i wanted to kind of take the time
to briefly introduce a few resources
that our team has developed to support
training and research in bioinformatics
as well as now data science for both
students and faculty to leverage
in their biomedical research or learn
about the publicly available data sets
and become proficient
in analytical methods to process analyze
and interpret these
effectively so the omics logic resources
are designed around
kiomics data types as chris mentioned
with big data cloud-based data analysis
tools
coding exercises in r and python as well
as
project-based tutorials that combine
biological or biomedical topics with
data analytics
statistical analysis principles and
curated data sets in a variety
of applications and so what our company
really does is provides an opportunity
for recent graduates and students to
leverage their skills
in bioinformatics and computational
biology to
train and mentor others with a growing
community of over 7 000
students worldwide and now a growing
community in louisiana which we're very
excited about
and so the academic oversight for work
is ensured by a close collaboration with
the tower bioinformatics research center
which is
at university of haifa in israel and is
directed by
dr alfred tauber and dr lena brodsky so
the center recently signed a memorandum
of understanding with louisiana state
university
to collaborate on research projects
expand these training programs and
establish faculty and student exchange
programs
so hopefully this will be possible after
the pandemic
but also due to the increased online
opportunities that have been highlighted
due to these unfortunate events as we
can see here in this virtual conference
hopefully virtual use of these resources
will be enhanced
so let me introduce the specific
solutions that we have been focused on
for the past several years recently as
was mentioned by chris
lbrn has started offering
research licenses to the tbi info
platform
which provides a simple and intuitive
user interface
for processing analysis and machine
learning methods for integration of
multi-onyx data
and to support the growing number of
users we're now offering processing the
data
on our shared server infrastructure as
well as on google
cloud so now we can run pipelines on our
servers
or you can send them to google cloud
directly and so we're now developing
pipelines that support the analysis of
omix data generated by the current
pandemic
such as the virology specific tools for
genomic data
generated by throughout this pandemic
and that includes evolutionary studies
host pathogen interaction and
interest host variation studies
importantly we're now focused on
developing user-friendly tools for
annotation and visualization of results
as well
and we hope that this will help link
significant signatures
found in genomic data with biologically
relevant visualization
and reporting capabilities and so we
hope that
these tools will help streamline the
analysis and reporting on important
genomic signatures
that will make the analysis results
clear to both as well as biologists
using these analytical pipelines we're
also
in final stages of completion for
validation of specific areas
of analysis that combine tools for
cancer research aging and virology
as well as a collection of tools for
multinomics integration which has been a
topic that has been discussed widely in
scientific literature
so these are uh available uh through the
lbrn pipelines
sorry licenses that could be requested
from the lbrm
we also realized that many users lack
some basic bioinformatics terminology
and necessary
kind of concepts to perform reproducible
analysis so in 2020
we launched a number of data science
training tutorials
combining our six omics specific course
collections
with this new resources developed to
help understand the code
behind many of the algorithms offering
training in statistical analysis
machine learning experimental design
data mining
and systems biology so these include
basic as well as more advanced tutorials
with browser-based
r and python exercises where users can
learn about scripting
some popular visualization data analysis
packages for
data science and learn how to apply
those to a variety of different data
types
so and as a result we started developing
a series of data science specific course
collections
that also break down the analytical and
different machine learning methods
into very short tutorials for
asynchronous use
and so we hope to increase using these
resources the capacity for data mining
and machine learning methods
so that those could be used effectively
to analyze
big data sets and do predictive analysis
and together with lbrn we're going to
start offering
these courses as program resources
they will be offered eventually with
lbrn certification
and we're now working with a number of
faculty
throughout the lprn campuses to help
integrate these asynchronous courses
into curricula offered throughout the
different puis
so to kind of briefly share with you
how we have used these materials over
the past year
and what are some of the ways that the
lbrm community can gain
access to these resources and materials
so as a part of our collaboration with
lbrn
we have this online complete
asynchronous course
that can be accessed by students
throughout the year at any time
starting with an introduction to
bioinformatics and learning about the
logic of data analysis
in application to various omics data
types so this is available
and i think we recently made an
announcement about that
so we will soon announce how people can
actually start that process
these basic materials are offered as an
introduction to bioinformatics module
which can be accessible to life science
students without
any previous experience in
bioinformatics the module covers the
basics of genomics in biomedical
applications
and we recently started the process of
offering this course as an undergraduate
course through the department of
biological sciences at lsu
and it can also be made available for
other campuses that might want to use it
as a gentle introduction to
bioinformatics
the coursework itself was developed
internally primarily but also
other contributors included faculty
such as this course on biomedical data
analysis developed by dr himanshu rajei
who graduated from lsu and is now a
professor at nicholls state university
in his course he offers an example of
pharma
pharmacogenomics testing using python
and gives a basic idea of what other
types of various biological data might
require
people to be familiar with
bioinformatics terminology
so based on the course work that was
already presented by chris
we also developed a course on
metagenomics to kind of
break it down into smaller pieces of
information that could be digested more
easily
and so these courses offer a variety of
processing tools that we've implemented
into the same
user-friendly interface and that
includes whole genome
mapping onto the database uh kind to
and data amplicon uh pipelines
with uh both a user-friendly and also
the coding aspect of visualization of
that data
so here you can see some of the examples
of the tutorials
including the uh the famous phylacy
package that is often used
we also have now a graduate course that
we offer jointly
with the division of biotechnology and
molecular medicine at louisiana state
university
it was led and organized by dr gus
kasulis
dr ramesh subramanian and the support of
dr farhana musarat
who is a postdoc at dr kusulus's lab
and as a result of that experience we
also formed a
graduate program on bioinformatics for
infectious diseases
where we use curated data sets from a
number of different epidemic outbreaks
to illustrate analysis methods relevant
for infectious disease monitoring
and biomedical research
using these resources we were able to
offer training to over 200 students in
the past year alone
throughout louisiana and so we collected
anonymous and specific feedback from
students and faculty
to help guide future development of
these resources
we learned that the materials resonated
well with the users and addressed a
pressing need among the student as well
as faculty
we also learned that the platform
developed a unique opportunity for many
to use
big data analysis tools for the first
time which otherwise they would not have
an opportunity to use
and many users reported a measurable
increase
in their understanding of technical
bioinformatics terminology
and understanding of how to practically
apply such methods
to different types of data sets and
challenges
and we're also excited to see many
undergraduate as well as
graduate students provide feedback for
the asynchronous training materials
the analytical pipelines that they've
used and participation in webinars that
was offered
in collaboration with lbrn and i think
that this is especially relevant because
we do have such a diverse population
of students that have very different
backgrounds and very different levels of
exposure to research
using bioinformatics and data science
and this includes both undergraduate
students and graduate students
throughout the elbow and primarily
undergraduate institutes
institutions as well as faculty that
were able to
learn about different aspects of
bioinformatics and even use
some of those tools in their own
research
so that's all i have for today thank you
for
inviting me to share this
all right uh thanks elia
um if there are any questions for any
either of the
either chris or elia now's a good time
um
the floor is open for questions if you
have any in there otherwise we'll
transition to dr
lee from there the only comment that we
make ramesh is that uh
all new funded projects will go through
review
by both course and for by our
statistician
before they are awarded uh and there
will be a
session where we're going to be
reviewing um
whether the appropriate tools have been
used or what else can be done to
help them move forward as we move
forward
and of course the same issue would be
with new applications coming in
they will be reviewed by both cores and
uh especially on the statistical side
to make sure that uh ahead of the game
we have been there
uh i think all of these things will be
available information on the
lbrn website um and
we you know i think we will be launching
a lot of these
ultimately would like to create a
curriculi in pui campuses that use those
tools
but we'll move forward with brn
certification
uh and hoping to have pui's adopt
certain of this material as chris uh
mentioned
in their own curricula as we move
forward so in the interest of time i
think we can proceed thank you